triangle strategy isn't the spiritual
successor to final fantasy tactics that
it appears to be though the hd2d game
certainly looks like the venerated
strategy rpg it quickly becomes clear
from playing that this is a game that
wants to forge its own identity with a
mixture of new ideas and streamline
systems and while some of these
improvements make for a better more
modernized take on the strategy game
others remove a level of player agency
and tactical character development that
were vital to making that classic feel
so special
the story of triangle strategy takes
place on the continent of norzelia which
is split into three nations glenbrook
ace frost and hyzanti each controls its
own particular natural resource that's
crucial to the survival of all three
kingdoms and that has led to conflict in
the past we pick up 30 years after the
salt iron war a conflict over hyzanti's
salt and ace frost's iron with a new
generation ready to put those past
prejudices behind them the story follows
sereno wilford of glenbrook the new
leader of a noble family known for its
heroism and efforts to protect the crown
sereno is on the verge of marrying
princess frederica for the neighboring
ace frost as a gesture of peace between
the nations their plans are interrupted
however by an attack that deposes the
king and puts sereno on the run with his
childhood best friend the prince roland
it's a story of war over resources old
grudges coming back to haunt a
generation that had nothing to do with
them and bad state actors invading a
neighboring nation under false pretenses
it's also incredibly dense and the
flowery prose drops references to lords
of high houses and their own individual
political machinations with the
unapologetic speed of a game of thrones
episode it's a lot to track and all of
this makes the game incredibly chatty to
its own detriment you'll often go long
stretches at a time without any gameplay
at all at times it feels like an
unnecessary degree of dialogue as the
squat pixelated characters go through
all the pleasantries before getting down
to business what a splendid facility you
have here
i can see why your nation excels in the
medical arts at 16 hours played so far i
would estimate that i've seen roughly 8
to 10 story missions although i spent a
fair amount of time on training missions
as well and this talkative quality means
it doesn't really put its best foot
forward as the first several hours
consist of a lot of very slow setup and
background story details before the
betrayals and political machinations
really begin there are also a handful of
free roaming segments where you can talk
to villagers and it behooves you to
speak to everyone you can for reasons
i'll explain later but i found my
interest in talking to everybody sapped
by having so much dialogue in general
once you do enter a battle the strategy
interface will be immediately familiar
to fans of final fantasy tactics or the
tactics over games your characters are
placed on a grid with various terrain
and height advantages and you have to
defeat all the given enemies or reach a
certain area to complete the mission
spell casters can target multiple
enemies at a time striking from behind
an enemy does extra damage and so on
this is the game at its most familiar
but also at its most streamlined where
it takes a scalpel to some of the
systems that longtime fft fans may take
for granted for example selecting a
healing spell will automatically target
whichever member of your party is in
range and needs healing the most you can
always manually select someone else to
heal but for the sake of convenience
this is a great quality of life feature
thank you there is no permadeath so you
can treat your units more like pieces on
a chessboard sometimes sacrifices are
necessary and as long as you walk away
with a single unit you win and you'll
have all those units back next time and
by default many of the offensive spells
will miss your own characters even if
they're in the area of effect that
change isn't necessarily better needing
to be cautious about slinging spells
actually made strategy more compellingly
complex in fft but it is one less thing
to think about in a game that adds other
wrinkles besides the positioning of your
units brings other nuances here if you
have an enemy surrounded on both sides
for example striking with one of your
characters will usually trigger a
follow-up attack from the other and they
can surround you in the same manner
triangle strategy is turned based on an
individual level so you'll need to plan
your moves knowing that enemies will be
acting in between a timeline at the
bottom of the screen is supposed to make
it easy to see when individual
characters will make their moves but so
far i've found it hard to read and not
all that important for most encounters
anyway another wrinkle comes from an
entirely separate currency kudos awarded
for completing special criteria in
battles like targeting multiple enemies
at once or exploiting an enemy's
elemental weakness those can then be
traded for quiet disabilities which are
especially powerful moves you can use
only one time permission since some
other strategy mechanics have been
streamlined compared to predecessors
these additional options help round out
the mechanics to offer enough complexity
for strategy fans to sink their teeth
into triangle strategy is class-based
but each character is their own unique
class and their progression is linear
sereno is always a generic knight his
friend roland is always a mounted lancer
his betrothed frederica is always a
pyromancer and so on you have little
choice in how they level up which feels
stifling when it comes time to head into
battle rather than creatively engineer a
solution to deal with a particular story
mission you always know you need to
bring your shield bearer to draw aggro
and your hawkboo to fire ranged shots it
strips missions of their individuality
when you're essentially always bringing
the same team into every battle and you
have no real ability to match your plans
or team composition to the moment you
can promote characters to an upgraded
class using items bought with kudos but
that just makes them a stronger cooler
looking version of the class they
already were this is especially a shame
because some characters actually do have
unique interesting class identities as
examples benedict is a tactician who
specializes in passive buffs and debuffs
including the ability to boost another
character's turn on the timeline so that
they can usually act twice in a row anna
is a spy giving her the unique ability
to strike twice or turn invisible and
one optional character an artisan can
build traps and ensnare enemies or
ladders to reach new areas of the
battlefield these are all great tools
but having them just reinforces the
desire for more freedom and flexibility
to experiment and build my own team
compositions creative combos and
tactical plans around them equally
inflexible is the equipment system you
don't actually buy much equipment at all
aside from accessories that grant
passive buffs just as the character's
class is set so is their weapon it can
be upgraded at a blacksmith with found
materials which gives you some
incremental buffs to stats like attack
or magic defense but you won't feel the
thrill of finding or purchasing a
powerful new weapon and heading into
battle to try it out the rigid class and
equipment system means you're more
dependent on your party's power level
than on broad strategic planning but the
main quest battles generally don't
provide enough experience points to keep
up with their own leveling
recommendations your best bet to grind
your levels up to snuff is to take part
in mock battles at your encampment but
there are only so many of these that
means to really raise your levels you'll
often need to take part in the same mock
battle over and over again i see a path
to victory alternatively you can fail
out of a story mission and keep all of
the xp you gain in the process but i
found this method of level raising to be
even more tedious which story missions
take place appears to be partly
determined by a branching story path in
which you'll be given choices on how to
engage with other kingdoms and nobles
this is part of the conviction system
which is frequently referenced but never
made clear the system itself is opaque a
black box in which you're assured your
choices matter but without ever
explaining how they've impacted the
story
you'll sometimes be presented with
dialogue choices that prioritize
attributes like justice versus kindness
but regardless of what you choose you'll
simply be told that your convictions
have been strengthened without any real
indication of what that means the rare
times your convictions do clearly matter
is when you and your closest advisors
are considering a big decision like
which kingdom to visit next or whether
to ally with a particular noble each
major character will have their own
opinions on the matter and they'll
express them in an effort to persuade
you but you can also persuade them
sometimes by collecting information from
talking to villagers or investigating
points of interest during the free
roaming segments and then matching your
dialogue responses to address their
concerns it's ultimately a very video
gaming system as you make your own
decision about how you want the vote to
go and then lobby for that result among
everyone who disagrees or is undecided
but it approximates the idea of holding
royal court in a way that's engaging and
often presents complex nuances of these
kingdom-shaking decisions and despite
your best efforts sometimes the vote
among your advisors doesn't go the way
you intended which accents the
character's identities as individuals
with their own strongly held beliefs
for all the emphasis on stark moral
choices and dialogue sequences though
the most impactful came in the context
of triangle strategy's battle mechanics
with a vastly superior hostile army
bearing down on a relatively small
domain my advisors and i formulated a
plan to use our secret weapon hidden
spigots of oil strategically placed
throughout the town could be activated
at key moments to set the enemy ablaze
the wildfires would route the invaders
but it would also burn down the houses
of my own people in the process
plenty of dialogue was devoted to this
in the story sequences leading up to the
moment but it wasn't until i was in the
mission itself that i felt the full
weight of using the weapon this wasn't a
mere dialogue choice i would have to
physically activate the spigots during
the battle itself some interstitial
dialogue made it clear that it is
possible albeit much much more difficult
to win on the strength of my forces and
my tactics but my army wasn't strong
enough or i wasn't smart enough when i
eventually stood victorious it was in
the smoldering wreckage of my village it
felt awful moments like those more than
any others are pulling me through the
experience in triangle strategy after a
plotting start i've become invested in
my band of trusted advisors all of whom
are trying their best to carefully
navigate a fraught mixture of war and
politics the strategy segments are
streamlined without feeling dumbed down
even if the class system is missing the
amount of flexibility and nuance that
i'd like most of all i want to see where
the story goes next and how else the
battle mechanics and story beats might
blend together to make an emotional
impact
[Music]